you don't have to say yes i'm just going
to ask a question that you can answer
your mind
but is it
bothering your
mind because if it is we all have an ego
if it's bothering you a little bit
then your ego's being a little bit quick
and you go but i don't really like to be
beaten
and and this is um
a big problem with like i still get it
you know if it doesn't work i still get
annoyed you can you can say
we couldn't see it scentsy but i could i
felt it you know so there's still
problems if um
if i go quite strong
and i go about here then this little bit
here that i get that block and i go well
i made it that's the main thing i made
here
uh
and those of you who have done it will
know if i go oh that's nice because what
i done was i actually like a straw as he
was squeezing i went
and i just
i didn't feel the block
but my partner didn't fill the block
here's the block there's the block
perhaps done it if i stimulate and this
to me this my hand direction is the same
now as nick's psalm
so if i believe in
you don't believe in spiritual stuff but
if i say well i'll go along with that
because if you're talking about angles
then if you put your hand that way then
the angle is going a different way than
what his arm is
if i go like that yes okay i'll agree
that his arm and your hand's gonna so so
to me
i've agreed with my partner so i've said
please go pass because i've agreed
if i go
he's not really old in me at all
that's coke you
right
so i don't know if any of you had a
light bulb moment at the moment does
everybody do you know what a light bulb
moment is well michael right a light
bulb mode is when something goes well
i've got here got it it's a real big
thing that comes together
what i realized cokey was was not this
power that i'm just breaking out of
its knowledge
so i realized that coke you actually
is knowledge if i do that
it's a different angle if i do that it's
the same anymore
so i've got knowledge to know that i'm
going in the same direction
if i go
a centimeter towards nick
they'll block me if i go a centimeter
away from nick
it'll block me
if i keep exactly
no centimeters anywhere we can
we can go
no you've got to hold them if you're
going to
so i mean so so it it doesn't matter
where the place is it doesn't matter
where it is but i mustn't
give him anything or take anything i
must go please go pass this is this is
the this is the
knowledge so so a week ago i had a light
bulb moment and i realized cocky
isn't this ultimate power to lift a car
or to throw somebody
four or five meters through the air
it's the knowledge
of knowing what to do so when he holds
him i'll go that's not
that's not being held
that's you know
so where's the contradiction
look i said don't go into him and meet
her i said don't come in but when i go
like that because i'm moving centimeters
are
you